let me talk to you a little bit about
one line AP tests in Django there's an
old math joke that this is a one-line
proof as long as we start sufficiently
far to the left and there's a sense in
which that's going to be true of these
as well so i guess i'm going to very
briefly introduce myself my PhD was on
human memory and forgetting i put people
in brain scanners to see how their
brains change as a result of learning
and to predict whether they would
remember something in future or not
actually scan my myself i was
disappointed by my brains smaller than i
had hoped and after that i teamed up
with ed cook who is a grandmaster of
memory together we attempted to blend
the very best ideas from the art and
science of memory to help people learn
up to ten times faster than you would
have believed possible and it really
works for everything from vocabulary and
languages like Chinese to facts in
history and geography to tropical fish
or Morse code and I owed you to check it
out if you're so minded and along the
way as the CTO we ran lots but not lots
of a/b tests in an attempt to try and
optimize everything from the signup flow
to the email emails that we send out to
the kind of game design and the
emotional messages and everything else
and we actually built our own internal
ad testing framework on which some of
these snippets will be based after that
I worked as a data scientist of the
Guardian helping build up their redshift
warehouse and Canada still a lot of the
best practices about a/b testing for
them I should say one more thing by the
way I am I don't really welcome but I
actually encourage interruptions so if
you feel the urge to contribute or have
a question or a suggestion then just
kind of make a noise like a startled
Mustang and I will know that you have
something you'd like to say so
definitely go for it now be more fun if
its interactive I think so quick
questions hands up if you have ever run
av-test okay great hands up if you in
fact know what an a/b test is okay great
and I guess hands up if you've used
Django great so I will kind of race
through the things that will hopefully
be obvious to most of you because that's
no fun to element okay so what's an a/b
test for me the core idea is that when
you're in the process of making lots and
lots of decisions whatever your product
or your thing that you are offering the
world where you're not quite sure is
this going to make things better or
worse the biggest concern that you have
is that having changed something you've
taken one step forward and two steps
back and I feel pretty confident that
this is true of almost everything if
it's not obvious whether you're taking a
step forward or back you're probably you
know tacking something almost easier
than well anyway I think most people
suffer this problem where they're
concerned that they might be making
things worse as well as or instead of
being better so in some sense and a/b
test is the application of the
scientific method to product design
where what we do is we say okay we're
about to mess with things we're going to
make sure that some people see the old
version of things some people see the
new version of things and we have a way
of measuring did we make them which
which groups happier is the old version
better or the old version worse do
people come back more often spend more
money report greater levels of
satisfaction sign up as a high
proportion with the new version than the
old version just make sense so far I'm
gonna gnawed on your behalf okay so
that's what an a/b test is and I know
that I know that there was a talk
yesterday and we're gonna I'm going to
come to some of the kind of ways in
which what I'm going to say might be
both kind of relevant and complementary
to what he said so why run a B tests I
think in some sense we know but let's
just talk it through so opinions are
like [ __ ] everyone's got one and
everyone thinks everyone else is stinks
in other words we have this problem
where we're trying to make decisions and
were like well I'm right and yet you
persist in having this opinion that is
contrary to mine like how do we
tunicate now it may be that I get paid
more or I hired you and therefore i win
but i might not in fact turn out to be
right so what would be more interesting
would be if we can find a way to say
okay let's try your version let's try my
version and let's see what the users
like best and one of the main advantages
of course of this besides that you
inexorably monotonically improve the
other thing is in some sense it takes a
lot of the emotional sting out of whose
decision ended up getting implemented so
in some ways it can be great for de
personalizing these debates okay this by
the way has nothing to do the talk but I
just thought it's funny if opinions are
like [ __ ] I work with a lot of
opinions anyway moving on nearly so the
second reason that AP tests are
important is because so let's say we're
at the Guardian I'm a designer and I
have determined that we need to change
the font that this is like the most
critical change that needs to happen and
so today we roll out a change where the
font moves from whatever Times New Roman
to Helvetica and I check the readership
tomorrow and I find that is gone up by
fifty percent so naturally I request a
very large pay rise now that seems
reasonable until you think well actually
it turns out the Guardian just broke the
Edward Snowden NSA story yesterday in
this evening and so that's what drove
the surge in traffic now if we run an
a/b test where half the users got the
old one and half the users got the new
font then both of them would show that
surge in traffic and by just looking at
the difference between them we'd be
controlling for that sort of
environmental factor that make sense ok
so now we got lots of scientists in the
room so maybe that's kind of obvious but
it's important and it means that a lot
of the hard stuff becomes about how you
set up the right controls but don't I
think the final point I want to make is
that there are many ways in which the
brain learns one of them is called arrow
driven learning and the basic idea is
this I'm going to predict what I think
is going to happen if I'm right great I
don't really have to do much learning
however if I predicted that this was
going to happen and something else
happens
that difference that between my
expectation and what resulted is a sign
that I need to update improve change my
model of the world in all the words I
need to learn somehow so that next time
I'm more likely to be right now if you
don't have that feedback if all you ever
do is act and you now find out whether
you did a good job or a bad job where
the world got better or got worse then
you don't have if you don't have that
feedback you don't know whether or not
to change your model in other words the
fact that I've changed the fonts a few
times in the Guardian I think I'm doing
a great job actually it might not be
making the blinds bit of difference i
might even making it worse and i won't
know because somebody else is doing
something that's sending the traffic up
or maybe just you know web traffic is
increasing year on you so in other words
only by running an a/b test where we've
controls all that external stuff can you
really be honestly confident that you
have improved things it's a to sort of
until you've made 100 changes and
realize you still don't know whether
you've done it better or worse you won't
really be gripped with the same
paralysis that I started to feel without
being scientific about things okay so it
enables you to improve your intuitions
over time by getting feedback like ah
that work that didn't interesting okay a
minor preface so um I think Martin gave
a talk yesterday which I was totally
unable to make unfortunately but my
understanding is that he talks about
some of the really important things that
you need to bear in mind in terms of the
statistical power and not peeking at
your experiment multiple times while
you're running it and we'll touch on
those issues a bit in some sense I'm
going to do something I feel a little
bit awkward about which is I'm going to
say sometimes those things are critical
sometimes you can think about the 8020 a
little bit and so a lot of this talk is
going to be about how can we make
pragmatic decisions and sums we're a bit
careful still be fairly confident
without worrying too much about the
stats and I wrote scientific software
for years
so I do care about that but there's a
sort of time in a place for making these
trade-offs so I'm going to be talking
about like low-hanging fruit stuff I'm
suggesting that what you really want to
do is look for big effect where it's
really clear you've made things better
or worse so definitely i'm inviting
questions about that stuff but also kind
of heading them off and saying this is
this is about the low-hanging fruit this
is about like the most practical kind of
decision making okay so let's talk a
tiny bit about code in a sense this is
the one line a/b test I was talking
about and you know I think the more
commonly amongst you might point out
it's not exactly one line so what you
want to be able to do is say okay I'm
going to run an a/b test on this user to
imagine they just come to your website
and you're trying to decide should I
show them the green button or should I
show them the red buck sounds kind of
trivial but you can imagine that it
could be a much more interesting change
way so the three arguments it takes are
the user the name of the experiment so
this is experiment 37 it's always
important you give it some kind of
unique ID or blower and we're going to
give it a label so that we can remember
what it is later this is the experiment
about whether or not it's given the red
or the green x button so far so good and
then this is in some sense the only sort
of vaguely contentious bit is we're
going to say okay in this experiment
there are two conditions there's red or
there's green now you might want to
label them differently maybe currently
the button is red so you might want to
label this red control or something
green experimental condition to reflect
the fact that one is the current state
of affairs and one is the new key point
is we're feeling in as arguments these
are the two conditions that I want to
choose between then you can simply say
okay well if my magic function told me
this person is in the red group great to
show them a red button if my magic
function told me this person is in the
green group group
show them the green button and this bit
of code should never run be a bug in our
av function if it ever does because it's
supposed to only return red or green in
questions so far okay quit so there are
many ways of sort of defining this
experiment model this is what we ended
up using for our internal framework and
it's kind of the simplest possible thing
that works and it's also designed to be
fast so we have an experiment table and
even if you don't know Django hopefully
if you know any sequel this should be
pretty straightforward where we're
saying okay the experiment has a name if
you remember before it was a 37 red
versus green x button or whatever it has
a creation date so you know when you
initiated the experiment so that you can
order them and the most recent
experiments come you know the top of the
list and then we're going to have an
association table experiment user that
says many-to-many this user is in this
experiment and there are obviously many
users in each experiment and in fact
each user can belong to multiple
experiments simultaneously you could be
testing the red versus the green x
button and also testing whether to send
them an email one hour or 24 hours after
sign up simultaneously those experiments
to be running in the user could be in
various buckets feature so far so good
the experiment user table is also as
simple as we can make it so this is the
one that says this used spam so we've
got a foreign key to user so Greg
whatever little foreign key to the
experiment experiment 37 red versus
green button and then the bucket is at
this point it's just a string now the
bucket might be red or it might be green
that's what we that's how we set things
up we know when we created it and we're
saying that each user can only be in a
given experiment once because you don't
want to accidentally end up in this
situation where you know I've been put
in both the red and the green buckets of
this experiment at that point you've
definitely made a mess I'm kind of sort
of waiting for someone to ask me whether
this should be a foreign key perhaps
I'll just proceed until someone does and
and so then our function is really
straightforward it just sits okay you've
told me that you're looking for
experiment 37 which is about red and
green by buttons okeydoke get me that
experiment if it doesn't already exist
create it okay so we've got this user
we've got this experiment get me the
road that tells me what bucket that
person is in if that road doesn't exist
create it and if we had to create it ie
if we haven't already assigned this user
to that experiment then we better make a
decision about which bucket to put them
in and update that row so in a sense
there's this is as deliberately
straightforward as possible and the
production code we built is more
complicated but not that much more
complicated and you know there are
smarter things one can do but I decided
not to worry too much about race
conditions and stuff like that because
in practice that unlikely to occur and
so what we're going to return is simply
red or green the reason to set it up
like this is because let's assume you're
doing continuous deployment so you're
deploying many times a day what you want
to be able to do
is deploy a change that says we're
before all the buttons were red we're
suddenly and be like actually when
making a decision it is going to be red
or green and then simply commit this
change to your code without having to do
anything to the database and then it
will automatically kind of dynamically
notice oh wait all of a sudden you're
asking me about this experiment 37 I
didn't know we will run an experiment
well I better creating experiment row
and I better assign start signing people
to it so in other words it means that
the business of running an a/b test is
as simple from the point of view of the
programmer as just adding a line like
that does that make sense right because
what you want to be able to do you want
to get to the point where people are
running a B tests all the time getting
results and then being like okay Red's
the way forward shut this down set
bucket equals red job done right and
only ever run this this first branch of
the code you want that so you want that
cycle of rut starting up an a/b test and
getting to a conclusion to be as
friction free as possible
then delete comment out do you do some
hack where or from a speedo allows it to
like 70 billion in the mountain that
says answer it it's a really good
question what we decided to do was say
well we've got a history and get saying
that at some point we ran an experiment
so let's just delete it set bucket to be
read and in a sense forget in the code
that there ever was an a/b test I'm not
certain that's the right move I think
the critical thing is that every
experiment needs a URL so you can you
know generator as a slug from the
experiment name or whatever but every
experiment needs a URL so that in six
months time when someone new joins and
you've left or whatever and we have it
we're like ahh I reckon we should make
the buy button green someone said hang
on hang on no we a be tested this we did
the red versus green thing and you know
I can't remember what we concluded
actually and so you can go back you can
look at your list of experiments that's
why they're stored in the database you
can see that oh yes those were the
results that we had last time so the
critical thing is that you can always go
back and see what the results were you
can if you want to reproduce them
because you know exactly you just have
to search in your code base through your
get logs for experiment 37 and that's
why you give each experiment a unique
number or whatever you've that's how we
did it because we actually use the same
numbering system in our ticket a
ticketing system but i think you know i
can imagine there'd be a case for doing
it differently the key point is just as
long as you can reproduce it sung as you
can always go back and see what your
results are then you're in in pretty
good shape results what are the results
yeah yeah thank you so I wasn't planning
to get too deep into the sequel because
honestly it just gets really hairy and
I've put I've started to put this cody
and github repository and i'll happily
talk a bit more about that but i think
this would be my suggestion for if
you're starting to implement a be test
for the first time this is how i would
start so basically what this is a graph
of is saying okay let's say you've come
to the site or the product or the iphone
app for the first time today what
proportion of people come back tomorrow
what proportion of people come back the
day after that and the day after that
and the day after that this notion of
retention is if you can if you're only
going to measure one thing that's what i
suggest you measure maybe actually I'd
suggest money which a be test group
needs to most money but you could argue
that both have their merits anyway if we
focus on retention for now this is the
graph that you want to produce so in a
sense it doesn't matter what the
experiment I'm talking about here is
control is red and the swap group is
blue so what we're seeing is that over
time the proportion of people coming
back to the site is higher for the blue
IE for the experimental new group and so
we can think of this av-test as being
pretty successful in order to be able to
do this what you'll really be able to
say is ok I want to know that this user
first came to the site on day zero did
they come back on day one did they come
back on day two did they come back on
day three and then you want to be able
to amalgamate that over over users so if
people are excited we can talk through
how to do the sequel for that and I can
point you towards where I'm starting to
put all this and github but I thought
I'd can start with just the high level
does that answer the question so this is
the current repository where I've been
putting code in it's one of those things
where I thought I was going to be really
easy to open source stuff because it
started out as a very clean nice django
app but i guess over time over a couple
years as usage
oliver sort of other codes started to
leak into it so it's it's there and
there's lots and lots of code that you
can use to build things on but the tests
and documentation is sort of still a
work in progress I've also put this
presentation up in there under the
presentations directory so along with
some notes and stuff so you're welcome
to go and have a look inside it okay I
guess I wanted a sort of move a little
bit to talking about some of the pro
tips some of the things that I learned
the hard way or by having long
conversations with people who are much
more experienced than me the first thing
that I think is really important is to
measure the right things don't if if
you're focusing on high level stuff
whether it be money or retention if you
can make those things go up you're in
pretty good shape if you if you were
only going to measure one number and
it's a consumer web or mobile app the
proportion of people that come back the
day after they sign up it's probably the
single most important thing you can
measure it's important because it's near
the top of the funnel so there's lots of
room to optimize it and if and it's
important because there's no way they're
going to be coming back on day 30 if
they didn't come back on day one does
that make sense and one of the first
things that you realize when you're
trying to build say something that's
growing really fast is that if you're
poor it you could have a fire hose and
be pouring it into a bucket if the
buckets leaking if it's got a big hole
in it then you're never going to fill it
up and the same is true of your website
you could have pretty great viral growth
but if hardly anybody comes back the day
after they signed up then your churn is
going to just kind of dribble away any
progress you might be making that make
sense second thing run on a subset of
your users so I'm assuming you have at
least enough traffic that this is a
feasible thing to attempt if you're
still really early then I guess you just
split it 5050 or evenly between your
experimental groups but if you can run
on a subset that way if you screw things
up the cost is
really low hue be test is catastrophic
and that the new condition is just awful
then you've only annoyed like a tiny
fraction of your user base what that
means of course is that it licenses you
be a bit more daring to try things that
are unlikely to work just in case they
do the talk yesterday was on false
positives on the concern you might think
you've found this new thing that's
better but actually it's not my biggest
concern is that actually people don't
bother running a be test at all and that
if they start to they get discouraged
because most of the results are going to
be null results like I really can't get
over the fact that and I've seen this in
papers as well nine out of ten a/b tests
basically it doesn't make the blindness
bit of difference red button green
button the main probably main problem is
your usability sucks or your server
keeps going down or whatever there's
almost always like big things and unless
your AP testing exactly the right stuff
then most of the time it won't make the
blinds bit of difference which is really
dispiriting anyway one way you can get
around that is by focusing your analysis
on just the users that are most relevant
so if you're making a change too i don't
know how fast the page loads you might
find that it's going to affect mobile
users a lot but web users don't really
care they're on a you know fast fast
connection and they don't really notice
the difference right so you may find
that only by looking at a subset of
users for whom the change is going to be
most relevant then you see the effect
remember how I talked about arrow driven
learning the idea that you make a
prediction about the world and then you
see if you're right and if you're not
right change the way you think about the
world that idea of making your
prediction first and write it down is so
important it's important because it
forces you to generate that prediction
and to sort of see that discrepancy and
because it forces you to understand
exactly why you're running the test and
what you think will happen that's over
time how you become much better and
making judgment about what's going to
work and what's not
and then we talked briefly about this
idea that each experiment should have a
URL however you choose to sort of
implement that whether it's even as
simple as just you know a page in your
internal wiki or whatever find a way to
consolidate your results so that you can
have a way of going back and seeing okay
this is what we discovered in the past
there's a few things to avoid and I
think Martin talked about a lot of the
more technical ones I'm gonna talk about
some high-level ones the first is not to
get lost in the weeds I remember having
conversation with one of our senior
adviser on the good word about this blah
blah blah so we're running a whole bunch
of a/b tests on you know headlines and
like the color of the font it's like
look don't get lost in the weeds most
this stuff won't make any difference
find the things that are really
important and focus on those so in other
words I think this fits with the
statistical power point from yesterday
look for big effect sizes unless you can
really see that this new version is
making a big difference probably it's
not that worth it now if your zinger and
you have sort of 700 billion people
coming through your site every day and
you're looking for every single
millimeter of advantage it's a
completely different game and that's not
what this talk is aimed at but for most
of us what you're really trying to do is
make a meaningful sort of sea change in
user behavior and if you're not noticing
that then it's basically a bust as far
as the result is don't expect your AV
testers see very often I don't come back
to that in a second and don't keep
checking the results basically you
statistically invalidate things if you
see how your AV test is doing every day
decide you're going to wait until n
whatever 500 or 10,000 people have been
through the experiment and only then
you're going to look at the results
otherwise by kicking you really
statistically and validate them and you
can make it much more likely you'll see
a spurious result that is something we
can go into but I think in some sense
that's all you need to know don't keep
looking under the covers wait till it's
finished cooking so there's a few sanity
checks and I'm a big fan of sanity check
so I wrote I have a talk that I really
like to give on like how to write
programs that aren't wrong which is
basically a whole bunch of ways
of checking but things aren't completely
screwed up so here's one way you can do
that with an a/b test run an a a test in
other words both buckets have a red
button if you see a difference between
the red button and the red button right
if the second red button appears to
magically improve your revenue you have
a problem you either don't have anywhere
near enough statistical power or more
likely you've got a bug right so it's a
really easy way to check that you aren't
being misled this is a particularly
unpopular suggestion try making things
worse and confirm that you have in fact
made things worse for instance and I
nearly had a fight with my co-founder
over this happy one but look sort of
fight I artificially include increased
the loading time the page by five
seconds so about ten percent by users
was sort of sitting there for like six
seconds racing for the page to load and
having a really crappy experience as a
result and the question I wanted no
words like how much does that affect
things because if we lose everyone then
I should be spending I should be really
worrying about four months if everybody
loves what we're doing so much that
they're kind of indifferent or they're
sort of busily planning whatever then I
shouldn't be worrying as much as I am
about performance right in other words
make things worse in so doing determine
the importance of that component is it
of course in an ideal world you make
them better and see how much that
improves things but it's hard to imagine
a wave a magic wand and say made
performance way better and see if people
like it more again it also tells you if
by making things a lot worse you see no
effect you might be screwing up your
measurement your results plotting I
think this is the lesson that I still
find hardest and maybe in a sense if you
only take one thing from this perhaps
this is the thought that the main
thought I thought writing the a/b
testing framework was the key part in
fact I kind of managed it in a couple of
days and I'm sure you could too couple
of models ads may be testing if this and
then plot the results
you can even sort of say well I'm not in
any hurry doesn't have to be real time
it can email me at midnight in which
case it doesn't even have to be fast the
initial version i did ran a single query
for sort of every single day and you end
up running 500 query so i was like who
cares let's not bother with the sequel
let's just make it run and see how we go
so I had this initial implementation in
a day or two and I was feeling pretty
smug what I hadn't realized is that the
software is the easy bit imagine the
following conversation your designer
whose judgment you mostly trust and
who's been to design school and spends
his entire time or her time thinking
about the interface and the visuals and
the experience and you tell them hmmm
science says no this new change is no
good right it didn't make any difference
you labored on a site redesign for a
month and honestly doesn't look like it
made the blanks with difference we were
wasting our time let's not do any more
redesigns right you can immediately
imagine how that person is going to feel
you end up having discussions about well
look you know I think you've got to just
trust your human judgment sometimes and
and a/b tests are a lot of work you know
you want it we want to add this big new
feature that's going to change every
single page slightly like you really
want me to a be test all of that it's
going to take ages it's going to mean
I've got to have the old code running
with the new code I can't just do a
straight migration so the program is
like this is a colossal amount more work
you sort of squared the context T of
everything like can't we just make the
change I just wrote all this new code
and you're telling me that actually if
it doesn't make a difference I'm gonna
have to throw away the code i just spent
a week right writing like you can
imagine how all of this stuff goes down
and you know I think I was probably too
forthright I just come out of my PhD I
just spent like you know years of my
life running psychology experiments I
was like this is this is how the hell
should be this is great I can be
scientific about everything I don't have
to worry about whether I'm right I can
just have an intuition generate my
hypothesis run a test and then I'll know
so all I'm warning you is that there is
an enormous merit to this it offers the
promise it was sort of monotonic
improvement but it's not straightforward
to build this into your team dynamics
into your through
company culture you have to have a kind
of quite humble and scientific company
ethos before this becomes as effective
as it can be I'm just warning you about
that ok so i guess i wanted to keep this
brief i want to leave loads of time for
questions i love thinking about the
stuff i love living at the intersection
of software engineering and kind of
science and starts up some products in
strategy so for me there's very little i
enjoy talking about more and so if you
ever want a brainstorm together who
welcome to drop me a line and i'll try
and chat it over with you and I guess I
also consult on a lot of this stuff too
I'm gonna yep so all of this is on the
abracadabra github page I don't know if
it's a good name or not so you're
welcomes download this presentation and
I included the four things that I found
most useful for thinking about a/b tests
so Eric Ries is the kind of evangelist
for a lot of this kind of lean startup
thinking these two papers are great
examples on why it's important on how to
implement this within a larger context
and to how to think about like dealing
with experiments a colossal scale where
you're sort of being or Google and
you're building a massive a/b testing
framework that can deal with dozens of
a/b tests running the same time and
analyzing the data and then Miller talks
at a lot about all the ways in which you
can screw it up but like I say the main
worry is you never get round to actually
doing it at all so worrying about
screwing it up you're already quite a
long way ahead of the game if that's
your concern so thank you very much for
attention
and you talked about obviously having
control so that you're always checking
whether it's in fact the fact that the
site's released something else but how
do you do was a phenomenal units so some
of your website looks new some people
beyond that because it's something new
something change how you go about being
with that did you go to ABCD test and
look at which of the new ones work so
what I what we did was to restrict the
analysis to people that signed up after
the a the experiment started running and
that way you don't have that problem
requires you to have a bit more data it
means you're throwing away the sort of
effect on all the people are already
part of your site and there might be
reasons why you'd be worrying about what
they think as well but that way at least
you're not having to think too hard
about it oh it no sorry I definitely
runnin ABCDEF tests and that the key
point is that I think what I was
imagining was that if you only analyze
the data for users that join your sort
of started using your product after the
experiment started running none of them
know what it was like before hand so for
them in the sense all of the buckets in
you that make sense
well I mean I suppose one thing you can
do is um so if you analyze the data for
just the users that have joined after
the experiment and you see that B is
doing better than a you can check
whether that's also true for users that
have been around for a while and if it's
different then okay now you have to
think a little bit harder about okay
there's an interaction between the
experiment conditions and the newness
and then maybe you can have a dialogue
with the old users and maybe part of the
issue is you need to have a forum where
they can complain and you can have a
community support manager who says well
I know it's new but you'll get used to
it oh okay well we'll add that feature
back in and then but yeah becomes a
dialogue rather than an imposition it
might Spence analyzing significance for
sings like retention is quite easy you
mentioned that you also advise to look
at reminisce which are not normally
distributed and it's much much to
analyze significance for readiness is
much harder have you actually done
something did you come across any
layperson yeah so I haven't um I haven't
done much work on revenue I did I looked
at it a little bit at the Guardian but
only very little bit I guess the reason
why analyzing revenue might make sense
is if I think ebay has an example where
they didn't a be test that men basically
there were fewer items being sold but
more of them were high value so you
might look at a straightforward metric
and maybe you might see retention go
slightly down volume of transactions
goes down but overall revenue might
increase you can imagine doing things
like The Guardian if you were to find
ways of monetizing new users more
heavily and monetize old users less
heavily for instance that might make
revenue go up but retention go down for
instance so I guess what I'm trying to
say is they don't always perfectly
correlate with one another
really thank you very much oh okay no
well I guess we look we got one more so
feel free to scamper if you feel people
advising using a a test run a just yeah
let's creating your test and trial it
for next month's or something and it
will be an ahs what's the point if you
can just sample the day to under- from
historical leave I mean if nothing else
you're making sure you're a be testing
machinery is working right because if
you see an effect for an a a test it
tells you either you're not doing your
sort of you're not thinking about your
statistics correctly or your machinery
is not working for some reason so that's
if nothing else do it at the beginning
right think of it as a unit test you
occasionally run or something how big of
a test your own obviously don't
subscribe but how big as I changes are
making less a juror interface because
you can change my new things and
technically really scientific but the
changes of the effects you see really
small and humble time but if you change
everything then you
if you lose one new feature that's good
how what can you do a kind of idea of
how bigger changes you're making yeah I
think that's really hard so the question
is how should you make lots of little
changes or should you make one big
change and how do you sort of think
about the spectrum in between I guess to
the extent that the big change you kind
of have to make it all at once because
it effects all of the various
interactions then it might make sense to
make the big change an a/b test that is
one thing but if you can split it up
into separate components that are
incensed independent orthogonal try and
do that remember not to get lost in the
weeds right so don't a B test a thousand
million things because unless you think
any of them are going to make a big
difference or a meaningful difference
whatever that means then don't bother
and I guess yeah I think those are the
sort of that's the balance you have to
strike I guess you could always try
making one big change and then looking
to see if there's a big effect and if
there is trying to break it down and
understand why the concern is always the
one step forward two steps back so if
you make a big change and it makes no
difference you don't know if is
certainly you didn't make things better
in some regards and worse than others so
the advantage of doing things and
individual components is you maximize
how much you're learning you maximize
how accurate the feedback your brain is
getting is and you might realize oh
that's interesting it was better in this
regard and worse in that regard